welcome back to the david pakman show i
am farin cousins from ring of fire
sitting in for david pakman i've been
sitting in for david all of this week he
will return to you on monday i promise
he has given me his word
but
let's finish things up here shall we and
of course as i've done every day this
week you gotta talk a little bit about
joe manchin public enemy number one
and now
we're finding out that republicans
including senate minority leader mitch
mcconnell are actively trying to recruit
joe manchin over to the dark side come
to us officially
they're telling him
and that's not hyperbole either
literally it's been reported that john
cornyn admitted
to sending joe manchin a text message
inviting him to come and join the
republican party in the senate
we're your friends you're just like us
come on joe what do you say
mitch mcconnell however
said in an interview with the new york
times
obviously we would love to have him on
our team i think he'd be more
comfortable
why in the world would they the
democrats want to call him a liar and
try to hot box him and embarrass him
i think the message is we don't want you
around obviously that is up to joe
manchin but he is clearly not welcome on
that side of the aisle
joe manchin himself this week
also
talked about the the bullying that he is
receiving from those on the left for
killing the buildback better act
and said you know they ought to push me
into the republican party
that's what he said
and i think these republicans took that
as
if they're not going to push you we're
going to try to pull you
so come on joe
and to be honest think about it this way
obviously if joe manchin were to leave
the democratic party go over to the
republicans they get the majority they
take over the committees and all of that
it's horrible right
right
is
it the democrats are already struggling
to get anything done
because they have only 50 and
republicans have 50.
and joe manchin
is the biggest roadblock
now i understand 100 percent if joe
manchin were to leave the democrats
become a republican give them the
majority nothing gets done
you know the voting rights act kiss that
goodbye
any chance of getting a different
version of build back better
gone
but what are the chances of those things
happening with joe manchin as a democrat
anyway
wouldn't it make more sense electorally
speaking
for the democrats to boot joe manchin
don't give him the option
tell him you're out
and then let the republicans take the
fall for it
the public wants the build back better
act
so if you can pin the whole thing on
republicans if joe manchin were to go
over there
wouldn't that be a better campaign
message
you know look we tried to give you all
these things and it got so bad that one
of our guys ended up becoming a
republican because he hates it so much
he doesn't want you to have good things
so he's joining the party
that continuously
refuses to let you have good things
because that's what they stand for
because that's who they are
so if you want these things
we got to get the majority back
now as again i've talked about that this
week
republicans have to defend 20 seats
20 seats
in 2022
that requires a lot of money
and the odds
significantly reduce that you're going
to hold on to every single one of those
seats the more you have to defend
you also have members who are
considering retirement some who've
already announced retirement so in those
new races of course that's going to be
far more expensive
and it opens the door
for a democrat challenger to seize the
seat so
democrats could probably come up with a
winning message
by getting rid of joe manchin
because again then the entire boogeyman
becomes the republican party
i'm just throwing it out there as a
possibility as a very real electoral
strategy that the democratic party
should at least consider
and if you're not willing to kick joe
manchiman out or not willing to push him
over to the other side
then at the very least don't let him get
his hands on the dnc money when he's not
going to support the democratic party
itself
i mean after all reports have also come
out this week saying that he's receiving
so much corporate cash right before he
announced that he was not
going to be supporting the build back
better act so joe manchin will be fine
hell he's not even up for re-election
for a while
so don't worry about him kick him out
make him part of the enemy
and see what you can come up with in
terms of electoral strategy messaging
once that happens
you keep him in the party
you're going to have to deal with him
and his problems and the negativity that
he brings with him
for at least another full year
and to me
personally i just don't think that's
worth it
your internet activity and data is being
observed by a variety of parties they're
selling your information they're
deciding what you can access don't let
it happen to you i use atlasvpn to keep
my internet traffic private from isps
tech platforms online marketers even
governments and atlas vpn keeps me
protected against hackers people
eavesdropping on networks to steal your
information if i turn on atlas vpn
before logging into netflix hulu or
amazon i can access streaming content
from other countries i can even watch
stuff from argentina like soccer i use
atlas vpn on all of my devices you
install it you turn it on once and then
you just forget about it and enjoy your
privacy you can read online about why
vpns are so important to use every day
really something you should have and
atlas vpn is having a huge sale giving
you 86 off comes out to like a dollar 39
a month for a subscription plus you'll
get three months free just go to atlas v
dot pn slash pacman and use the code
pacman the link is down below